foreign
spacesuits science fiction
space stations
with NASA's Artemis Mission we're going
back to the Moon in for the first time
in 50 years and this time we're the
first woman on the moon
you may also have heard that we're
planning to send humans to the surface
of Mars and the logistics and rocketry
for for this long and gorgeous Mission
are going to be figured out eventually
but shockingly one of the big problems
we don't have a solution for is
something that most people don't think
about and that is food what are we going
to feed the astronauts going to Mars it
turns out it's incredibly complicated
before we go there I'd like to go over
why I am here talking to you about this
I am an industrial designer and an
aerospace architect
I run a design firm called non-fiction
and what we do is that we take science
fiction and we make it real
it's a real job
just to give you an idea of like the
type of work that we do here are a few
examples
we take technology and we make it a
natural extension of the human body
we'll work with prominent you know
scientists and design wearables that
help people fall asleep and stay asleep
all night we designed batteries low cost
for Rural Africa
we build schools that support
neurodiversity and lifelong learning
we turn humans into superhumans
so as you can see my I love working on
projects that make the world a better
place through design but most
importantly I love food
I've been told that food is my love
language when I like someone I feed them
one I don't like someone well there's
always Pizza
[Laughter]
so when I found out about this space
food competition put together by NASA
the Canadian space agency and Methuselah
Foundation I knew I had to be part of it
it's called the deep space food
challenge
the premise of the challenge is to
figure out what and how we're going to
see the astronauts on their way to a
deep space mission like going to Mars
so sending living and breathing uh
humans to to Mars or a deep space
mission is very tricky as you can
imagine going to Mars is going to be
extremely dangerous
um the the round trip is going to last
two and a half to three years the whole
time we're going to be bombarded with
life-threatening levels of space
radiation and we're going to float in
microgravity or or stand on the surface
of Mars experiencing one third of
Earth's gravity right so it's it's
really uncomfortable to be up there and
so all of these conditions on top of
isolation and stress are going to make
it very hard for astronauts to keep
their weight and their health at optimal
levels
and one of the main culprits of of them
losing their weight is actually
unappetizing food so imagine having to
eat things like this for three years
straight right and looking at the same
five people that's going to be really
hard
so
um what I'd like to go over is what
astronaut eats aboard the international
space stations for example right now
so essentially they have access to ready
ready to eat food or food or
freeze-dried food like you can see here
that's rehydrated with water
um and so
um it's either goop in a bag or if
you're feeling fancy you can place that
goop in a space tortilla
so tortilla is actually very popular in
space because it satisfies like bread
but doesn't crumble and clog the air
filtration system now the quality of
that tortilla will make your Mexican
grandmother roll over in her grave but
it's better than nothing
by the way the water that rehydrates the
freeze-dried food is recycled again and
again we don't have the luxury to send
all the water that we need
so there's no romantic way of saying it
it's filtered gray water and tea
oh
every once in a while astronauts or body
ISS have access to fresh produce and
that comes from resupply Rockets
this happens because the Earth is only
250 miles from the surface from from the
the space station and that's not going
to be an option for people going to Mars
because that's 300 million miles away
one way
right they're not going to send like a
small rocket with like apples and
oranges just for you
so going to Mars is going to be very
hard it's like hardcore backpacking EX
in the wild except the wild is a cramped
space surrounded by things that can kill
you at any moment
so packing food for Mars is going to
require one ton per person per year
so if we have a crew of five six
astronauts that's a lot of weight and if
there's one thing you need to learn
about space is that weight is money
so what my design team came up with is
this amazing system called the space
culinary lab by the way we won the first
phase of this competition and I'm
currently working on prototypes
so let's go over the four sections of
this of this machine
step one coffee
in the morning it's nice to have a rich
creamy hot beverage a nutritious version
of this is butter coffee
what would you take for astronauts to
make space butter coffee
so one of our team members created this
mechanical homogenizer that breaks down
coffee granules hot water
collagen and ghee together increased
this unctuous satisfying mouth feel
solution that that is really nice to
drink
what's nice as well is that it provides
you with omega-3 fatty acids that can
protect your your brain and your heart
as well as reduce inflammation
step two snacks
microalgae like spirulina research in
animals has shown that it can also boost
your immune system and help your body
from developing cancer but the problem
is algae is gross it's it smells funny
and it doesn't taste that great so what
we can do is cultivate a fresh fresh
batch aboard the spaceship dehydrate the
microalgae and mix it with our
ingredients we can mix it with oats with
nuts with powdered berries with spices
we can make them sweet sour Savory spicy
whatever your heart desires oh and as a
bonus growing micro microalgae absorbs
carbon dioxides from the air and
produces oxygen
in in other terms is carbon negative so
now imagine all of the food systems that
we have on the surface of the Earth what
if producing food actually reverse
climate change wouldn't that be cool
three salads
when astronauts go on Long missions to
to to space one of the things they look
forward to the most when they come back
to earth is the crunch of a salad so
salads were designed to grow with
gravity so now we're asking it to grow
without gravity well thankfully the
International Space Station experiments
have proven us that we can do that with
lettuce with kale and with other greens
so let's give our Mars explorers a um a
space Garden right it's great to give
them some some fresh produce too to eat
once in a while and it's it's nice for
the mental health to look at a garden
once in a while
last but not least step four space
barbecue
so a lot of a lot of cultures all over
the world consider grilled protein a
meal centerpiece unfortunately open fire
is found upon in space
so we're gonna use lasers right so we're
going to take a piece of chicken for
example and we're going to rehydrate it
with a carbohydrate solution and then
from there we're going to design a grill
pattern on top of the chicken using
lasers and so the heat carbohydrate and
protein combination creates the
signature caramelization that makes
barbecued meat taste and smell so
delicious
with the space culinary lab we can
imagine all the combinations of flavors
textures colors and rituals even that
that can come out of this what if
michelinster start Chef had access to
this kind of system and create their own
space-borne dishes
like think
um astrobesque
um
space floating space juice caviar or
space whiskey
what is traditionally called a galley or
Prep Station is now something that looks
and feels a lot more like a farm to
table kitchen but in space
what we want to do really is to take all
of that space Innovation and bring it
back to to other places in in space
right we're going to go to the Moon
we're going to go to Mars and what we
really want to do at the end is make
space more human we want to apply this
to online support systems up there
so that's and and bringing all of that
technology back to Earth is nothing new
by the way like we um we've been using a
lot of the Technologies uh every day
that were invented in space for example
solar cells uh Prosthetics water
filtration system GPS wireless
communication device even the lens on
your camera phone
so you know when we think about taking
all of that um that technology that
we're developing in in space what we
want to do really is uh create uh
regenerative ways to replace
non-regenerative agricultural methods
that demand too much
resources on Earth
every day there's a lot of space
Innovation that's happening in space
that's here to benefit us on Earth
so one day not so far into the future
maybe the way we create food in space
will help us open the door to become a
sustainable
and to planetary species
thank you
[Applause]